i wanted to talk a little bit about
working with uh martin scorsese because
you jump into a movie like that i
imagine there have to be expectations
that come with working
with a director like him and so what
were those
expectations and how did he exceed them
walking onto his sets
it's like walking into church or
something really it's it's like you
could hear a pin drop
um and everybody is
just knows that place everything is very
there is a kind of ritual to the whole
thing it's like
all these people who have been working
with him for years and years and adore
him and
and are adored by him um but
everybody from the kind of the person
that's bringing you your
cup of tea to the sound person to the
costume designer you know sandy powell
they're all
they're all uh you know at the absolute
top of their game i mean they are all
the most brilliant people
in our industry um and
to be surrounded by those people and to
be
able to have the benefit of their
expected expertise
is just is so crazy it's so wonderful
and it is really intimidating but in the
kind of best way
um and you just feel
i don't know there's something about
there's something about working with
people who are so good at what they do
when working with martin scorsese who's
so good about
what he does that it's sort of the
nerves
are that the terror and the horror of
the situation is completely mitigated by
the fact that they are
so expert and so good and so
and you're it's not sort of they've
chosen you because they want you or
something like it
it very quickly doesn't feel
like well i mean of course in the back
of my head there's always a feeling of
like this is a mistake like i
this was a terrible mistake this was
some
piece of paperwork got mixed up and i
shouldn't really be here at all someone
else called emily
should be here um but but
he doesn't he really doesn't make you
feel like that you know that's just the
voices in your head
the reason that he makes movies is
because he loves movies
he's an uh you know cinephile by like
bar none and
and and so there's such enthusiasm
for the process of making a film and
he's so ungrand about it and every shot
that you
that he's creating it's all um
it's all like oh this is a [ __ ] he'll
say oh you know you're lying in this
scene so i'm gonna put the camera above
your head because
in every hitchcock scene when someone's
when a character's lying or not telling
the truth
the camera's looking down at them um
from higher than they are and
and and he just is getting such a kick
out of it that
you do too and it sort of stopped
there's it doesn't feel precious it just
feels very
you know precise and good and
uh he has a great talent that the great
filmmakers have of
of of just somehow by some osmosis or
something like
you understand the world that you're in
that you understand the world that he's
creating
and you know kind of half your job is
done because
he just help he just he lets it be clear
what the world is and
and you can just enter it and go with it
you